okay good morning everyone my name is
Jerry dunno I'm with the National
geospatial Intelligence Agency
I really appreciate the flight data
folks letting us have a slot to speak
here at the conference the first thing
you'll probably notice is I have no
slides and there will be no equations
and no coding in my in my to speak my
speech I'm not a data science person I'm
actually a self production professor
Luddite and I make that profession on
purpose because I don't want to as a
person who's been in a position of
leadership within our agency and the
government I think it's very dangerous
to get to the point where you think you
know enough to make a decision in a
technical area where you have a bunch of
smart people around you who can provide
you better information or better data so
I try to leave that to the people who
really know what they're doing the
reason I don't have any charts today is
because I really want to talk to you
about culture and the culture around
what we call the data occupation within
our agency and the culture of leaders
mindsets and making decisions so I'm
going to assume that everyone at this
event knows that people who make
decisions without data are really always
making the best decision in fact
behavioral psychologists have proven
over time that although we think we're
really good decision-makers when we make
decisions without data we make almost
always make the least optimized decision
that we could make and because I've been
in positions to make decisions both and
financial and human resources as well as
risk based decisions based on operations
I think it's really exciting where our
agency is going with regards to the data
occupation and the technology and
capabilities and systems that we're
bringing in to support data-driven
decisions within our agency so let me
tell you first a little bit about me so
I'm a retired Air Force officer and
joined the agency in nineteen I'm sorry
in 2002 so I've been with the agency for
about 15 years and then
of different leadership positions some
of those have been operations
organizations where we deployed units
overseas to different locations for a
lot of different reasons both DoD
Department of Defense support and combat
operations but additionally humanitarian
assistance support such as the Ebola
crisis in West Africa my most recent job
before my courage job I was the director
of analysis where we make
recommendations or provide advice to
government decision-makers across the
full spectrum of the government so that
they can make decisions and we always
try try to provide the best advice we
can based on the data that we have but
one thing if anybody in the audience has
been in government will know most of the
people who rise to the position of
decision-maker in government are
generally type-a people who think they
know everything they need to know about
making decisions in the environment
they're in because that's how they got
to where they are and I found a couple
years ago I was sitting in a panel at
Georgetown University on big data and a
reporter from the New York Times asked
me a question about what we were doing
with data because we spent a lot of time
in the last couple of years structuring
a lot of our data and building up
systems that allow us to use data
differently and he said as a government
leader how are you going to ensure that
the data is the appropriate data and
structured and formatted in a way that
allows you to make the best decision and
the only response I could give them is
I'm going to have to trust the data and
the people who we bring into the agency
to wrangle the data to structure the
data the data engineers as our data
scientists to make sure that I'm getting
the data in a way that makes sense for
the problem that we're trying to solve
that's not the mindset that most
bureaucratic decision makers have I
remember when I was in the Air Force
talking to a general officer about a
decision one time based on imagery that
we had received and the general
made me go get the imagery and show it
to him so that he could interpret the
image himself in order to make a
decision because when you get down to
those kinds of decisions where there are
grand strategic policy decisions or
life-or-death decisions based on an
operation a lot of times the individual
making that decision will only trust the
data if he or she sees it and we all
know in today's environment we're not
going to be able to see all the data so
you're going to have to trust the data
so I've got experience based on both my
military time and my time serving as a
government civilian that have allowed me
to change my mindset but that isn't
necessarily prevalent throughout the
rest of the government so it's important
for me to find a way for to help make
change the culture and get people to
make decisions differently and our
agency is doing a lot to drive in that
direction investing a lot in I heard the
keynote speaker this morning talking
about some of the technologies so we've
invested a lot in containerization to
build algorithm libraries we've invested
a lot in Python and building coding
skills and trying to get some of our
most of our agency what we call data
savvy or at least understanding what
data can do for you so what is nga for
those that don't know the National
geospatial Intelligence Agency is a
member of the intelligence community and
the Department of Defense and we provide
advice to decision-makers in order to
prevent problems from happening that's
our main objective we need data to do
that typically when people think about
geospatial intelligence they think about
imagery they think of the satellites
that take imagery but imagery is just
the foundation layer of Geo analysis
there's everything that happens in the
world happens someplace at some time so
it's geospatially and temporally
rectified in order to provide a piece of
data and all that data pulled together
helps us find things out and learn
things and make decisions most of you
probably know what GPS is or Google
Earth or use nav systems in your car
those are investments that nga has made
throughout our history
that the commercial side has turned into
commercial viable commercially viable
products but we use to bring in data to
our agency among those in addition to
Google Earth and GPS our commercial
imagery companies like digital globe
that a lot of people use to provide to
you to find unclassified data to help
make decisions so we support national
security and humanitarian efforts I'll
give you a couple examples of how things
happened a while ago talking ten plus
years ago that have also helped shape my
mindset and helped me try to drive
towards a different approach one example
is when we after 9/11 we had units going
in and out of countries conducting
operations and the intelligence units
that went in to support them would come
in with their own data drop in for a
period of time six months to a year and
then leave with their data another unit
would come back in and essentially
wiping the history of what happened in
that place over the course of that six
months or year for the next unit that
was coming in and they had to start all
over because we couldn't find a way to
make the data accessible to everyone to
allow us to make smarter decisions or
understand things over a longer period
of time so through technology and
architecture we were able to solve that
solution or solve that problem another
example is the Ebola crisis which I
talked about earlier so we worked with
the units that were going over there to
support from the Department of Defense
side to help them understand where were
the best places to put the Ebola
treatment units in order to make sure we
were having the biggest impact possible
on that crisis that required us to look
at a lot of data in order to make those
decisions and because of that event in
particular our director Robert Cardillo
in 2014 for the first time made all of
our data available on the World Wide Web
so that marks a significant shift in our
agency's approach to be able to put
things out on a completely unclassified
environment
the reason we needed to do that is there
are so many people let me change that
not needed to do that preferred to and
chose to do that is there were so many
people that needed that information that
didn't have access to our architecture
and we didn't have access to their data
and this just left a huge gap from a
mission perspective in making sure we
were able to support the needs of the
humanitarian organizations the
non-governmental organizations Red Cross
and those types of organizations to be
able to make the best decisions so we
have a lot of data within the agency and
a lot of data coming in all the time as
a matter of fact the amount of data
that's coming in is getting to be more
than we can possibly happen handle we've
moved from hunting within one image for
the perfect piece of information to help
us about that moment in time and that
place on earth to trying to create
coherence from a flood of data that's
coming in all the time through different
sources some of it classified and some
of it unclassified but it's a lot of
data and we're starting to think about
how we develop models of things that
happen around the world in order to give
predictive and be able to address a
problem before it happens so how much
data are we talking about at this we
have a conference once a year called the
geo and symposium and our director spoke
there last month and he believes we're
standing where the Sigyn community stood
when the internet became the digital
fabric of the planet we really think
geospatial information is about to be
that next fabric of the planet in how we
approach data and whether it's a
persistent view from space or air or
ground or even the sea in five years
there's probably going to be a million
times more data than we have right now
and are unable to get through all of it
right now
so just for comparison's sakes if we
were to try to manually look at all the
data all the commercial satellite data
that's coming in today and that we
expect to have over the next 20 years we
would need 8 million
to take a look at that that's a lot more
than we'll ever have so we need to find
a way to automate things and find other
technology solutions and that's all in
HD we have so much data right now we
can't take advantage of it all we simply
can't look at it all we can't organize
it all we can't visualize at all we
can't use all the data that we have so
we have to focus the resources we have
on the very hardest problems and find
ways to work with other organizations so
it's a nexus for innovation for us on
how we manage and use our data to answer
analytic questions we have taken some
steps in structuring and standardizing
datasets and spatially enabling them
from non geo and sources such as open
source information new press and those
kinds of things large integrated
multi-source data enables types of
correlation alerting and forensic
analysis that has resulted in
discoveries of new new systems new
insight and new detail on relatively
well-known targets and an ability to
ferret out patterns of life and
observable activities of some of the
hardest intelligence targets however
even though we've made progress in
structuring and standardizing the
datasets we still haven't realized the
full extent of what big data analysis
can do for us we need to spend more on
algorithm development on automation this
has been a decades-long problem for us
that we've been trying to solve with
significant investment and get to
spatiotemporal processing of remote
sensing data that allows our analysts to
focus on the really difficult challenges
we're working with key partners in
academia and several universities as
well as in R&D organizations to try to
achieve this what we'd like to do is
distill down all the data into
meaningful insights predictions and
other bits of information this isn't
unique to the intelligence community
we've heard speakers this morning talk
about how they're trying to do that for
investments for their organizations for
how to help match people to a vacation
home etc they're all the same problems
when it comes to the data perspective
ultimately we'd like to make the systems
a tool for our analysts so they don't
have to spend so much time working on
the data and getting it right but using
the data to answer questions make have
easier and better tools for interacting
with the data open up our systems so we
they have more access to data across the
government in fact about a two years ago
Senator Warner from Virginia wrote a
letter about how just basically screwed
up the geospatial information is across
the government now I'm not talking
specifically about our agency this is
government-wide a lot of municipal and
state governments have done a good job
of bringing their data together to help
make decisions on infrastructure systems
and investment decisions from a state
and local budget perspective but within
the federal government because there are
so many different agencies with so many
different stores of data that is that's
all treated and handled and used in
different ways it really is kind of a
mess that's one way to put it I describe
it as a huge opportunity for us to be
able to bring all that data together and
help the government make better
decisions we need systems and algorithms
to correlate that data and find needles
in haystacks and the capabilities that
go beyond and answer specific questions
the cultural challenges are the hardest
and I think even at our own agency
they're the hardest but I think we're
ahead of everybody else because our
leadership has made investments in these
capabilities including what I mentioned
earlier some pilot projects with
containerization and approaches to data
science it's going to take a big effort
to change this culture though and be
able to use a multiple a multitude of
sources and large volumes of data we're
investing a lot in training and
resources for our analysts to fill my
eyes them with and equip them to make
sense of all the data but we're not
going to be able to tackle those big
data problems alone we need close
partners with industry academia and
research and development organizations
now most of what I've talked about so
far has been what we call about what we
call mission data so that's the imagery
or
data about things that happen in places
on the earth but we also have a
challenge within government and within
our own agency on what I call the
corporate data side so this is how do
you use the dollars that the taxpayers
have given us through Congress to the
greatest effect and how do you use the
people who work in the agency to the
greatest effect so we've actually
started structuring all of our corporate
data in a way that helps us make smarter
decisions and determine what the return
on investment is from those decisions
and we've seen some change some shifts
in our leadership and how they make
those decisions from listening to people
who have really good sales pitches about
really good potential outcomes based on
investment to listening to our data
folks who have pulled the data together
in a way that those decision-makers
haven't seen before we use tableau a
fair amount for a lot of our HR
decisions and we're starting to look at
different ways to look at our financial
decisions using different tools so we're
trying to start a new conversation
across different entities to make sure
we're getting the best and the brightest
input that doesn't necessarily mean
people coming to work for us we want
that but also means people working with
us so we have programs with universities
like Penn State George Mason and other
major universities that work specific
projects with us using unclassified
information so and when I say
unclassified it's different than what I
heard unclassified in the previous
conversation I'm assuming that's
understood but we're trying to find ways
to open up our data and take as much
data as we had where we have and do what
we did with the Ebola crisis just put it
out there for people to use and help us
from a crowdsourcing perspective solve
some problems so we're standing up and
impro a program we call engage where
we're sending some of our folks out to
universities or companies to work in
those environments and help get up to
speed on the current state of technology
and capabilities but also to bring
people into our agency for short periods
time to bring their capabilities and
their knowledge and experience into nga
to help us understand how we can do
things better we've also built outposts
in different locations we have one in
Silicon Valley where we have a couple of
folks who are we're sitting there with
startups and other corporations to try
to understand what's the current state
help us have those conversations and
decrease the gap between what the
current state is outside of government
and the current state of Technology and
capabilities inside the government we
also put one in New York City we have
one in st. Louis which is our second
largest location where we're working
with some pretty major IT companies to
be able to teach our folks and get our
folks some experience we've also come up
with what we call a data investment
process this is part of the culture
change for the agency the process is
actually pretty straightforward but it's
a little out of the ordinary for the
government so the first rule of the
process is we break the assumed rules of
the intelligence community so the
assumed rules are you know we have our
information and our data and we don't
share it with anybody outside of the
intelligence community because you don't
have a need-to-know or you don't have
the architecture that we want you to
work with it on but we know that a lot
of that data can be used outside of our
architecture and with other people so
the data information doesn't have to be
kept secret not all of it just what
needs to be we can solve we can't solve
our problems alone so we need help to do
that and that was something we
determined we needed to come out and ask
for help with so the first thing we're
going to do is find the data inside nga
that we can use to invest in this way
and that's why we need more data savvy
or data experienced folks to come in and
help us work with that we're working on
that right now and that's what I would
call the hard but straightforward part
of the problem once we have that data we
would call that our capital in place we
can form our investment fund to invest
in this capital that might come in the
form of asking Co investors to chip in
their own data
so that we can work together on problems
so imagine nga in the Air Force or nga
and Google or nga and GrubHub working on
a large a problem together to co-invest
that's very similar to the approach
we've taken in the past
I mentioned GPS and Google Earth and
digital globe same kind of approach but
that was not with data that was about
technology this is now about data and
we're uniquely postured and uniquely
experienced to be able to do that so
we're looking for companies and
investors who have the skill and talent
and want to work with us that way we
realize that's not everybody where we
are the intelligence community we know
some people don't want any attachment
with that but we also know there are a
lot of people who want to serve their
government without putting on a uniform
or necessarily getting a government job
and this provides an opportunity to help
serve directly with these or with our
organization so we're looking for a
company that's looking to build change
detection algorithms we have a huge
amount of data that we can provide to
train and test your algorithms to help
refine them or a company interested in
looking at for example hyperspectral
imagery and what we can find from that
using different data approaches we have
a lot of experience in this area and we
can work together to both entities
benefits it wouldn't be a contract
that's another thing that's different
about this approach so in the government
you have to it takes a long time to get
a contract in place and execute it
usually by the time you get all that
done the problem is moved on to a
different stage or is even disappeared
but this approach wouldn't be a contract
they wouldn't necessarily involve the
exchange of money they might not have a
specific requirement rather it would be
an investment that both sides would make
to find the right team and the right
ideas to solve the problems to help both
sides grow the investment that they make
in the problem
if data is the new oil this is a
catchphrase we have now we want these
companies to go make petrochemical
products right turn it into plastic and
build something for us turn it into a
change detection algorithm or into a
crazy new way to use hyper spectral
imagery or a new automated way of
labeling objects in images which
something that we may have never
considered before you know we work in a
very talking about culture again a very
homogenous environment that we're trying
to break down we realized that that
homogeneity of the people that the
government attracts doesn't allow us to
take the right approaches to every
problem and so we're trying to open that
up and get more diversity of thought in
the way we approach our problems so in
exchange for our investment in that type
of arrangement we'd like a return on
that investment so in this case for us
the return looks like better data and
better technology some value added to
what we started with and put into the
investment that's our return so if a
company does come up with a great change
detection algorithm then we can feel
free to use it and share it and they can
sell it commercially and we both win we
just want to be able to use it inside we
think this is a win-win because NGA gets
new and innovative technology and that
gives us a competitive advantage against
those who are trying to create those
problems that we're trying to prevent
and the investors and inventors get a
competitive edge of their own so our
goal is to drive innovation and create a
culture of innovation especially around
data and the data occupations within our
agency ultimately it's to ensure we're
able to better carry out our missions
and that can be mutually beneficial so
we want to unlock the power of all the
data that we have and we know we're just
at the tip of the iceberg in trying to
do that right now so with that we have a
sense that we want it to be more than
just about an innovation for nga and for
the GEOINT community we want it to be
about results and mission outcomes so
we're looking to people like you and to
organizations
that you represent and companies that
you represent to partner with us and to
join with us in addressing the problems
that the nation needs to solve and with
that I'll stop and take some questions
if anyone has any so for the classified
data are you allowed to tell us what the
domain the data is in I'm not nosy I'm
just trying to figure out what NJ does
what good so I start I'll start at the
end with what nga does hello so we we do
look at all sources of data but our
primary mission is looking at imagery so
you're whether it's from satellites
government satellites or commercial
satellites or aircraft drones etc that
are taking pictures or video or whatever
of the earth but we also take in all
kinds of other form of data to try to
determine what's happening at a specific
place at a specific time and answer some
questions about for example in the news
this weekend right North Korea launched
a missile so we're trying to make sure
we're preventing our enemies from being
able to have a capability to strike the
United States that's one of our mission
areas I mentioned the Ebola mission
early earlier so one of our other key
missions is understanding the earth and
what that usually has to do with is what
we call safety of navigation so making
sure aircraft and ships and vehicles can
transit wherever they need to transit
safely without running into each other
or things etc and so in the case of the
Ebola mission we used that side of our
mission area to understand where the
Ebola treatment units could go you know
what the terrain was like so how fast
could people get to the units if they
got sick those kinds of things so and we
do work on a number of different domains
most of them are internal domains to the
agency or to the intelligence community
so did I answer your question yeah so I
would say we have some folks here who
are smarter than I am on that so I'll
ask him to correct me but probably 90
plus percent of our data currently is
kept in a classified domain 90 plus
percent however that doesn't mean that
much of that data is classified and
that's what I was trying to get at
through this discussion is I think a lot
of that data can actually be openly
shared it's because of security policies
and regulations and laws that we aren't
able to do that right now
but we have started challenging those
laws and policies in a way that allowed
us for example during the Ebola crisis
to share information out on the World
Wide Web so I'm kind of curious about
collaboration between you all and the
other intelligence agencies do you do
the other are the other intelligence
agencies more customers of both like the
data and the analysis and the products
that you're building or is the data kind
of thrown over the wall and they're
building their own tooling I'm curious
like how much sharing of like so you've
built all these great tools to analyze
the data
how much sharing there is between you
and the other intelligence agencies
again and I'll ask for help there it's a
combination so we do provide a lot of
our specific data to other agencies for
them to synthesize with other
information from other agencies but
because of the nature of our data we
actually can answer a lot of questions
in some cases were the only data that
exists in other cases because it's all
geo spatially and temporally rectified
we can answer the questions that we
normally throw the data over the fence
to others to answer so it's a
combination of the two but there is a
lot of collaboration going on Hey so you
mentioned that you guys do
collaborations with like universities
what kind of problems are you looking to
solve with universities like we see yeah
right so there are a lot of different
ones I think them
prominent one currently is illegal
wildlife trafficking we have a huge
effort against that that one of our
officers is leading working with a
number of different universities but we
look at a lot of different problems for
example you know where to make
investments in infrastructure in
developing countries those kinds of
things so we're open to anything and
most of the domain knowledge is imagery
I guess or no so we have again we we
bring in folks who have domain knowledge
for example in a country or a region or
in a technology for example we have a
lot of Engineers who work as analysts
looking at R&D for other systems and
those kinds of things so it's it's a mix
okay so I'm also in academia so how do I
get in touch with somebody from say the
geospatial agency - so we have a table
out here with some folks that can give
you a contact number if you have a
specific problem you want to work thank
you
use your hand up hey so I know you
mentioned you're kind of a Luddite but I
was wondering if you had any kind of big
picture ideas on how the intelligence
community or other government
organizations can support the tooling
that's used primarily in the open-source
by both you guys and other people yeah
so so I say let and that might be a bit
of an overstatement I'm that deep okay
at and you need it you need to at least
understand technology to lead some folks
but then trust them and their answers
but we have made investments already and
have done some things for example we're
on github with some of our algorithms
right so we're trying to find ways where
we can be out there and be more open and
transformative and if like I mentioned
during the talk we're looking for other
ways we can do that right we were in
github because we had somebody in the
agency who knew about github and said
hey we should go do this where we've
made the investment in containerization
with doctors and mezzos because we took
a trip out to the west coast and someone
said hey we should we should do that so
we just need people to tell us how we
can do more of that
does anybody want to add anything good
all right
I just wanted to ask him is there a way
an individual could be involved in this
engage program yeah yeah I think so
I mean that hasn't come up but you know
our approach to all of this is why not
so I would say again get with the folks
at the booth and we have a person in
charge of that program they can put you
in touch with her okay
any more questions thank you Gary
thank you
[Applause]